let's talk about how to stay calm when
you're stressed
and you have high levels of cortisol now
if you live on planet earth you may have
experienced stress
at least once in your life and i'm being
very sarcastic because it seems like the
motto is to keep your adrenals jacked up
and keep you in stress mode 24
7. and anytime you're trying to solve a
problem it's vital to understand the
problem a little bit more so we're going
to do a deep dive into the main hormones
that
regulate stress and those two hormones
are both cortisol and adrenaline and
they're both produced by your adrenal
glands and you've got two adrenal glands
they sit on top of the kidney you have
an outside and you have it inside
the inside is all neurological tissue
and that is where adrenaline is produced
and released from
the outside is all glandular tissue and
that's where you have cortisol and
cortisol is the hormone but adrenaline
is a neurotransmitter
which is similar to a hormone but it
works through the nervous system
and both of these hormones basically
adapt your body to
stress states so the more
environmental stress you have the more
those adrenals have to be activated to
adjust your body to survive better
during stress events these two hormones
are not designed to be long duration
they're designed to be of a short
duration and then turn off now the
problem is
the adrenal glands
were not built with an off switch
they only have an on switch you probably
heard of the flight or fight mechanism
as a part of the autonomic nervous
system and that is called the
sympathetic nervous system that's the on
switch
the off switch is called the
parasympathetic nervous system and they
call that rest and digest because it
occurs when you're in a calm
relaxed state
so if you happen to get stuck in stress
like a lot of people you're going to be
heavy on the sympathetic nervous system
the flutter fight and very very light on
the parasympathetic so we're going to
talk about how to reverse that but the
big problem is the adrenal glands don't
have
any parasympathetic control it's all
sympathetic control so there's no off
switch but i'm going to show you what to
do now when we talk about the
sympathetic nervous system
in flight or fight i want to focus more
on the word flight okay what is flight
that means to run away from
that has a lot to do with a fear state
and when i talk about fear i'm talking
about other emotions like anxiety
and worry so anytime you are worried or
have anxiety
that is a type of fear that you're
avoiding things you're resisting things
you're going in the opposite direction
but stress in general is a very
necessary thing for survival
it causes our body to adapt and become
stronger so we don't want to not
experience any stress but it's the
overwhelming stress that gets us and
it's also the long-term chronic stress
that
causes our body to get stuck in stress
to the point where now we can't turn it
off so a lot of different parts of our
body tend to get stuck in stress and i'm
going to talk about the effects of that
so what happens when your body becomes
stressed
and cortisol is activated what occurs
let's take it from the top
the first thing that's going to happen
is that you're not going to be able to
sleep in fact you may find that you're
getting up at about 2 a.m in the morning
that's when cortisol is supposed to be
at the lowest so you have the situation
where you're waking up at 2
and you're completely awake yet the best
sleep is in the morning when you're
supposed to wake up so you have this
reverse of these hormonal rhythms
circadian rhythms where cortisol is high
at the exact wrong time
now i had this problem for about 12
years so i know a lot about it and it
was literally destroying my life until i
figured out some things that i'm going
to share with you that i apply to my
body to eventually sleep and turn things
around but if you can't sleep you're
never going to be able to heal your
adrenal glands all right the next thing
is the heart
the heart is greatly affected by high
levels of chronic cortisol output
in in both blood pressure
heart rate and
inflammation inside the arteries now
cortisol is an anti-inflammatory
in fact they use synthetic cortisol
called prednisone
in all conditions involving inflammation
but the problem is when you have chronic
elevation of cortisol over many many
months or years you start developing
resistance to that cortisol in the
receptor and now you don't get the
effects of cortisol much like insulin
resistance you get cortisol resistance
where if cortisol increases you have
more inflammation and you have more of
the symptoms it's supposed to protect
you from
so too much cortisol over a long period
of time will keep you
in an inflamed state and this prompts
the need for medication and people start
taking anti-inflammatories prednisone
for all sorts of inflammatory conditions
especially like arthritis autoimmune
issues
joint inflammation that's usually years
of stress and cortisol where cortisol
now doesn't work anymore so you just get
the negative effects of cortisol and not
the positive ones now this next function
with cortisol is
fascinating it affects your white blood
cells the immune system
normally cortisol is supposed to
suppress
your immune system and turn it off
because it's trying to protect you
against this over
reactive immune system where you have
too much inflammation so cortisol tends
to put the immune system
on
pause for a while and that's what it
does
in fact cortisol inactivates or turns
off a very important specific t cell
called the natural killer t cell which
normally does two things it kills
viruses and it kills
cancer cells
so the more cortisol you have in your
body the less immune system you're going
to have over a period of time in fact
this is why
nearly everyone who gets an infection or
gets sick
had a stress event just before that
because the stress activates cortisol
and closes the door on the immune system
so your body cannot fight it anymore
so stress makes you more susceptible to
viruses
bacteria
fungus mold etc in fact certain bacteria
have a strategy to try to get the
advantage over
this whole battle with the immune system
by activating
your hypothalamus to produce hormones to
then activate cortisol because it knows
if the cortisol goes up
the immune system goes down and it can
have the advantage
fascinating all right now the
relationship between cortisol and memory
is interesting initially cortisol is
designed to help with short-term
memories of emotional events
to help you survive but the problem with
chronic cortisol is it destroys
something called a hippocampus which is
like the relay
switch for your memories and so you end
up having memory loss you end up having
brain fog you can't focus anymore in
fact you're fixated on
like one or two problems 24 7 where you
just cannot not think of that problem so
your wheel starts spinning you start
solving problems when you're not
supposed to be solving problems in the
middle of the night that's what happens
with a chronic exposure to cortisol
so you might be in problem solving but
your solutions are not that great all
right the next thing that happens is you
start losing certain minerals and
vitamins
specifically potassium so you start
losing potassium potassium is a mineral
to create a physiological relaxation
state so without potassium
your pulse rate starts going up you get
stress so there is a massive loss of
potassium on top of an already huge
potassium deficiency in the general
population because they don't consume
enough high potassium foods like
vegetables and they consume a lot of
sugar which also depletes your potassium
now the next thing that you lose and
this is very very important to know
about is vitamin b1 thymine thiamine is
the key anti-stress vitamin when you
take thymine it gives you a sense of
calmness you feel relaxed
you lose the stress effect so stress and
high cortisol deplete b1 but also b1
lowers stress and lowers cortisol and
will increase other things like gaba
which is very calming now you also lose
this h plus it's called the hydrogen ion
okay and all you need to know about that
is that that's an acid and so when you
lose your acid you end up with a
a state where your ph is more alkaline
so when you have people in chronic
cortisol states or high stress they
become more alkaline
not acid and then they have problems
with their muscles being tight they get
little twitches they have tetany they
get muscle cramps they can't
absorb electrolytes that well and they
have a lot of other issues especially
with breathing their breathing is off
but what initially happens is when you
have high cortisols you might have a
spike in acid so you might have acid
reflux and then you lose your acids and
it starts going down and now you don't
have enough stomach acid so you have
digestive issues but other than that
you're going to be doing totally fine
all right next effect is a catabolic
effect what's that that is where your
muscles start becoming broken down so
the body is increasing cortisol to turn
your muscles into the basic
building blocks amino acids which then
can be converted to sugar so your body
is trying to
give you quick energy
with sugar or glucose from your muscles
okay but it also dismantles collagen
from your joints and your skin as well
as elastin which is a type of protein so
it makes you wrinkly and looking older
don't worry it gets a little bit worse
cortisol also destroys your bones it
creates osteopenia and osteoporosis this
is why during menopause when you lose
the function of the ovaries the adrenals
have to work twice as hard and act as a
backup to the ovaries and if they're
weak and going in the menopause you end
up with all sorts of adrenal
overwhelm issues your adrenals become
fatigued and they can't keep up with the
extra demand all right let's talk about
the kidney what happens with high
cortisol with the kidney
you filter less so you have less
filtration and that means you do not
filter
enough of certain minerals like
potassium and magnesium and you lose
those minerals okay so that's one
mechanism of losing certain minerals but
you retain
sodium and this is why adrenal cases
have a lot of fluid retention
okay so
there is a condition where your adrenals
are burnt out
where you're losing sodium okay and
you're retaining potassium that is more
rare so i don't want to cover that in
this presentation but
it's called addison's where you need to
be consuming a lot of salt and you don't
want to be consuming a lot of potassium
because you're losing salt very rare
most people have the opposite problem or
maybe a subclinical version of high
cortisol and it's called cushing's all
right the next point about cortisol is
this increase in glucose or sugar
another name for cortisol is
glucocorticoids because it helps to
regulate glucose and helps to release
stored glucose it helps to make glucose
from non-carbohydrate sources like your
protein like in fat even ketones and
this is why cortisol can activate
insulin and make you fat around the gut
and give you all the negative effects of
high insulin which i've done a million
videos on all right now with digestion
now remember digestion is all about the
parasympathetic nervous system control
so that's rest and digest that's the off
switch so you're going to digest when
you have the least amount of stress when
you have high levels of cortisol
digestion becomes inactive and sluggish
and you have all sorts of issues with
digestion and bloating and you can also
develop ulcers so you need low stress
low cortisol to be able to digest and
absorb nutrients now i already mentioned
belly fat in relationship to cortisol
but that comes from high insulin because
the cortisol is just turning everything
into sugar and releasing a lot of
unnecessary sugar
for this quick
energy all right low vitamin d occurs
with high cortisol
what's interesting about vitamin d is
that it can act like
cortisol but without the side effects
vitamin d is a very powerful
anti-inflammatory
it's very very important in the immune
system it actually helps to suppress the
immune system but it doesn't turn it off
it helps to enhance the immune system
and it can help to
minimize or curb the inflammation or
situations where you have the cytokine
storm where you have too much
inflammation all right so as you can see
high levels of cortisol over a period of
time
is very very bad
all right enough of the bad news let's
talk about the good news what can we do
about it how can we lower cortisol how
can we remain calm despite
this stressful environment okay
the first thing to do and i think this
is very important i've done a individual
video on this is to balance all this
mental stress which our body has not
adapted to yet our bodies are not
designed to deal with the amount of
mental stress that we go through but to
balance out this mental stress with
physical stress or physical work
to do physical work around the house but
it might be better to do it outside do
it in nature
very therapeutic to get rid of mental
stress to do physical work physical work
is going to get your mind off the stress
it's going to get more blood flow it's
going to make you get tired and help you
sleep mental stress might make you tired
but it doesn't help you sleep so more
physical work is
very very important if not the most
important thing and you can also do
exercise which is more organized type
physical activity the physical work is a
little bit better but you know both
would be a good thing all right number
two you want to stay in action you want
to stay moving because when you're in a
state of worry when you're in a state of
anxiety when you're in the state of fear
your body is kind of paralyzed
you pretty much are not doing much
you're withdrawing you're not an action
and that's just going to keep the stress
there the more you're in action doing
things the less stress you're going to
be all right number three
like i said before vitamin b1 thyamine
is the most important vitamin with
stress if you haven't
taken
b1 when you're stressed
you won't appreciate the significance or
the impact that that can create
i will usually take nutritional yeast i
take them in a tablet when i'm stressed
and it's just like a switch it's just
within minutes i just feel calm i feel
good i can cope with stress if you
haven't tried that that is definitely
something you need to
have as your go to all right the next
two minerals that are very important
stress is magnesium
and potassium and guess what they're
both found in these things called
vegetables okay so having a big salad
every single day is very important in
keeping the minerals high so you can
actually counter stress
as compared to just having protein which
can just kind of keep you wired and
protein doesn't have enough potassium
and magnesium and then on top of that if
you're adding carbs not a good situation
carbohydrates actually keep you in that
sympathetic flat or fight
mode now vitamin d is also
a necessary key vitamin
to lower your stress and increase your
mood
you're going to feel much better when
you have vitamin d
there are so many people that are
depressed and they're kind of in this
paralyzed mode and they don't know that
it's coming from the vitamin d and
vitamin d can actually help to act like
cortisol but without the side effects so
it can help get rid of inflammation and
also fulfill a lot of other functions
with your immune system etc etc the next
thing number four is to get on the
healthy version of keto as well as
intermittent fasting
both of those actions will increase the
opposite of the sympathetics the
parasympathetic control of your nervous
system they're going to make you calm
you're going to feel better you're going
to have more cognitive function you're
going to have less stress
you're going to have less brain fog
you're going to be able to cope with
stress much better and it's going to
bring your mood up
from anxiety to a much higher level of
calmness all right number five uh taking
a really good supplement that has really
good adaptogens these are herbal
um things that help you
increase your coping with stress
i'm gonna put a link down below of the
one that i recommend for that all right
number six
the combination of correct breathing
with sleep let me explain when you're
under stress mode your breathing is
going to be off
either your inhalation or your
exhalation is going to be too short or
too long it's not going to be
equal
if you can get your breathing in and out
equal you're going to sleep a lot better
because that puts some control over the
autonomic nervous system in fact just be
aware when you're stressed what happens
with your breathing especially if you're
trying to sleep so what you want to do
when you go to bed is start focusing on
your breath just breathing in
slowly in
and breathing out
to match
the inhalation to the exhalation okay
and it doesn't matter if it's five
seconds four seconds or three seconds
just start focusing on balancing
those two things and you're gonna find
your sleep is going to be much better
and in addition to that there are a lot
of things that i want to tell you about
sleep in this video but i'm going to
i'll share with you in the next video
but sleep is a vital thing
to
fix
if you're not sleeping and you have
stress in fact let me just put some
links down below
in the description for sleep
specifically if you have that issue all
right the last thing i'm going to talk
about and this is very very cool
it's a stress extraction technique that
i developed and i will teach you this
technique
it's very simple to do on yourself but
it is something that i came up with
after years of practice that i would do
on my patients and myself and it can
create some serious stress relief
and i want to show you how to do it so i
created this video and you just need to
click on it right now and check it out
you